I have an interesting rate problem here
and at first it's a little daunting
because it has fractions but then when
we work through it step by step
hopefully it'll feel a little bit more
intuitive
so it says Calvin cleans three fifths of
his bathroom with one third of a bottle
of cleaning solution at this rate what
fraction of the bottle of cleaning
solution will Calvin use to clean his
entire bathroom and like always
encourage you to pause the video and try
to take a stab at this yourself so as I
mentioned it's a little bit you know
it's a 3/5 of his bathroom with one
third of a bottle how do we think about
this and what my brain does is I like to
say well how would we like to answer the
question what fraction of the bottle of
cleaning solution will Calvin use to
clean his entire bathroom so we want to
figure out is we want to figure out how
many bottles so question mark question
mark bottles bottles / let me write it
this way so we want to figure out he
uses a certain number up with that
question mark bottles bottles / bathroom
if we knew this then we have the answer
to the question if this would this might
be I don't know two-fifths bottles
two-fifths of a bottle / bathroom it
might be two bottles per bathroom but if
we know whatever this question mark is
and we know the answer how many bottles
doesn't need to take to clean a bathroom
or what fraction of a bottle we don't
know that they're they're hinting that
it's a fraction of a bottle but how much
of a bottle or how many bottles per
bathroom or another way to think about
this if we want to know if we wanted to
express it as a as a rate more
mathematically we could say question
mark bottles bottles per bathroom
bathroom and the reason why this is
helpful it makes it clear that look we
want to figure out we want to take our
unit to tell us that we want to divide
the number of bottles or the fraction of
a bottle it takes to clean the number of
bathrooms or a certain fraction of the
bathrooms and they tell us over here
they tell us that it he's able to take
one-third of a bottle he's able to take
one-third of a bottle so I could write
it here one-third
of a bottle to clean to clean
three-fifths of a bathroom three-fifths
of a bathroom three-fifths of a bathroom
so hopefully it's clear now why this was
helpful we say okay we want to take how
many bottles it takes to clean a certain
number of bathrooms one third of a
bottle take can clean three-fifths of a
bathroom it makes it clear that we need
to take the 1/3 and divide it by 3/5
because then we're going to get bottles
per bathroom we're gonna get the rate
we're not going to get bathrooms per
bottle we're gonna get bottles per
bathroom which is what we care about
what fraction of the bottle will it will
it take to clean entire bathroom to
clean one entire bathroom so now we just
have to take 1/3 and divided it by 3/5
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to I can write it this
way 1/3 divided by 3/5 divided by 3/5
and the units are going to be bottles
per bathroom I'll write it like that
bottles or since if we know that that's
going to be a fraction we can just say
bottle per bathroom bottle for bathroom
and so this is going to be the same
thing as well we're gonna have 1/3
divided by 3/5 is the same thing as 1/3
times the reciprocal of 3/5 so 1/3 times
5/3 one-third times 5/3 bottle per
bathroom so let me write that down
bottle per bathroom bottle per bathroom
and what is this going to be well we
multiply the numerators 1 times 5 is
going to give us 5 and the denominator 3
times 3 is Knights there's going to be
five ninths of a bottle of a bottle per
bathroom / / bathroom I wrote these a
little bit further apart than I would
want to let me write that a little bit
closer together five ninths five ninths
of a bottle / bathroom
so just as a reminder of what we did
here it could see him a little bit
daunting but we said okay look he we
want how much I'm what fraction of the
bottle to clean his entire bathroom so
we care about bottles per bathroom or
since we're talking about a fraction I
guess we could just say bottle some
fraction of a bottle per bathroom so
it's bottled / bathrooms that's gonna
give us the correct rate so took one
third of a bottle to clean three fifths
of a bathroom so you divide one third by
three fifths you get five ninths of a
bottle per bathroom so this question
mark right over here that is five ninths
it takes five ninths of a bottle of
cleaning solution to clean his entire
bathroom